you don't want to really take pride in
your work or try to take pride in your
work because your job sucks so if you
took pride in your work what would
happen when you take pride to work do
they pay you less like no but I had to
put up with my boss's [__] you have
to put up with this [__] one way or
another your cynical ass puts up with
this bull that's why you're cynical
London is like my spirit place I'd
London is the greatest place on Earth
and I love hearing all that Harry Potter
[__] I [__] Can't Get Enough
anything in a British accent is just
Superior I wish I spoke with a British
accent you sound smarter cooler James
Bond sex with random girls alcoholism
you know all the James Bond stuff like
my culture is not your costume okay so I
suggest that you stop putting it on and
laughing as mine because that is heavily
appropriating and it's not yours to wear
yeah I'm actually I was born in Russia
so I actually wholly appropriated the
language of your birth Nation it's just
really offensive right let's get started
Mike Israel welcome to the show
thanks for having me Chris I'm super
pumped to be here man what is the
pessimistic fallacy
is a cognitive bias
that the average person shares
is a very very prevalent not everyone
has it most people have it to some
degree
and that cognitive bias is to take any
scenario any given presentation of data
any sort of prediction of the future
specifically predictions of you know we
have this situation how is it going to
unfold is the situation going to stay
roughly the same poverty for example uh
how is poverty how bad is it now how has
it been going has poverty been
decreasing over time has it been
increasing over time has it been roughly
stable in 10 20 30 years how do you
predict poverty will go will it get much
better will it improve will it stay
roughly the same and there has been a
profound amount of research done on this
uh Hans rossling's book factfulness is
probably a really good place to go for
it a great sort of high level summary
but uh without putting too fine a point
on it almost everyone is insanely wrong
about understanding how the world works
and that wrongness isn't um it's not
normally distributed it's not just some
people overestimate some people
underestimate most people not all but
most are
you would think inexplicably pessimistic
they think that things used to be better
in the past where in fact it's almost
almost always not the case they think on
almost any Global scenario that things
are very bad today uh to put it more
technically worse today than they really
are if we examine the empirical evidence
and their predictions for the future
again tend to be it very pessimistically
inclined such that uh they not only
think this but a sort of in-baked maybe
a sort of subsidiary of the fallacies if
you try to point it out to people it's
an iterative Loop if they apply the
pessimistic fallacy to argue back to you
so they go well you're just a Pollyanna
like you just think it's all hunky-dory
and they just apply another layer of
pessimism to your attempt to correct
them and it's tough because you end up
it's very easy to caricate yourself when
you're a pessimist as a realist or at
least you're hedging your understanding
you're like if things turn out better
hey amazing but I think they're going to
be worse and the worst case scenario
they turn out better uh uh best case
scenario I'm right which other which
either one of those worst cases it's
kind of like a hedging the BET situation
and that's a common retort so that tends
to be how the pessimistic fallacy is
expressed yeah what was that thing about
um the myth of wage stagnation I thought
that was a really good example of this
yes
it's a very common citation that people
will Trot out on social media and by
citation I just mean claim are what uh
The Economist and philosopher Thomas
Soul would call notion it's something
people just say or think it's not even
caricatured as a hypothesis because it's
not falsifiable or testable and that
idea is that like will wages haven't
gone up uh typically they'll say you
know in the United States since and then
on surduck year depending what
literature they think they've read
typically the comparator years 1970 year
the 70s sometimes it's the 80s and if
you look into this with like more than
like five minutes of Googling it just
falls apart right in front of you I can
get it a little technical as to how it
falls apart and then why if that's okay
so if you look at
um wages for certain kinds of jobs
then you actually can conclude that
there has been a significant amount of
wage stagnation what that typically
doesn't integrate is a few things first
of all
that is not looking at flesh and blood
human beings over time the people that
had a given job in the 1970s in 75 80 85
90 typically their remuneration has
skyrocketed they're like wow they have
seniority they're older so that doesn't
count okay so we're not actually talking
about real people that go to work and
and have the same wage year and year out
and if you push people on they're like
okay that's not what I mean what about
new people coming in and then you start
comparing well is it really the same job
and then that sort of floats away look
at that really the same job it turns out
that we're actually comparing much
easier jobs so they used to pay really
good wages for brutal like Central
Indiana factory work with no air
conditioning or chance of death was like
decent and nowadays you just press a
button and the Machine dumps the steel
into the cooling chamber and you're
drunk the entire time and you're a union
member you can't get fired no big deal
it's a totally a non-comparable work and
another big one is a lot of times they
don't compare they compare wages and
wages in some sectors have gone up a
little bit or actually stagnated but
they don't compare total compensation so
in the 1970s you got your wage middle
finger see you tomorrow and your you
know shift number one nowadays and over
time since the 70s until today you're
getting an insanely richer uh offering
of health benefits
daycare time off bonus structure
a bunch of different other ways to
compensation so if you are and I don't
want to say intellectually honest
because that says the opposing side is
intellectually dishonest usually they're
not just people hear stuff and there's
pessimistic fallacy rounds in it or duh
and
if you are trying to find intellectually
the best comparison what you're gonna do
is look for a better comparison more a
more valid comparison and something like
median income is a good idea mean
average income like GDP per capita it's
a little tainted because like if you
have a trillion billionaires and
everyone else is dirt poor more
billionaires they just drag up that
average but the median doesn't drag up
the average uh so the Richer super rich
people and super poor people don't drag
it up so you really are looking at like
what does the average person make if you
look at median income and total
compensation that has just been going
like that for every modern Western
Country for as long as you can measure
it and that that is the reality of what
people are saying because when they say
things like wages and you go like most
many people aren't even paid in what you
would call wage some people get salary
some people get bonus structures people
get various other compensation and so uh
I remember uh Thomas Soul had a famous
line where he said you know if someone's
talking about household income they're
for sure are just trying to use that
metric because they're trying to paint
it in a bad light why household like
what because household sizes have
changed households are much smaller now
so if household income hasn't increased
the per capita income actually has gone
up a ton because now households are two
people that used to be six so if people
are saying wages of stagnated and these
are the term wages they're trying to
make things seem bad an honest
assessment would look a total comp total
median compensation per industry per
field per IQ per whatever and any
logical assessment of that sort of like
97 of the time the honest assessment is
actually things have gotten phenomenally
better for almost everyone there
absolutely are exceptions to what about
inflation what about the cost of housing
what about the cost of goods what about
cost of living what about all of that
doesn't that just erode away all of the
gains that have just been made
so
we can take a look at a few of these
inflation is a decent Point except
inflation has been relatively stable
over a very long term
and so it's hard to paint a particular
era of human history is bad because
inflation is kind of a really steady
thing that happens all the time
and it's not even true to say that
inflation lately other than the past
well six months ago and now it's kind of
stabilized anytime inflation here's
another thing really quick anytime
inflation uncharacteristically
uncharacteristically goes up people
spazz the [__] out inflation killing us
what happens when inflation is is low
for a five-year period nobody talks
about it you don't even get an article
about it so you're like yeah like you
only pay attention when inflation is
really bad so in if inflation is sort of
uh anachronistically high is absolutely
a concern usually that's just not a
concern
first point second point is the uh there
is another as I said so like median uh
average income uh median uh income per
capita is a good way to think of how
much money people make another way to
integrate the cost of goods and services
it's what's called time cost or time
price
and it's for an hour of typical
typically compensated work how much
stuff can you buy and that reflects some
integration of inflation and everything
like that and time price of almost
everything just goes down all the time
that's the most integrated holistic
honest assessment and it's improving all
the time there are exceptions to that
I'll get to those in just a second but
you can say look okay with inflation the
picture isn't as good as without so with
a lower inflation the picture would be
better totally true
however
almost no analyzes even in formal
economics integrate the quality of goods
because that is phenomenally difficult
to quantify so for example say hello I
only had to work XYZ number of years to
buy a car 19 said my uncle worked for a
summer in 1976 bought himself a great
car now we got a slave way for years
well what was the car in the 1970s like
finding any given metric it was a
[__] disaster it's actually illegal
to drive most those cars on the road
because they just like the global
warming actually comes out of the
exhaust pipe it's not even pollutants
it's just like straight up like little
Al Gore particles come out so and it's
the thing is like weighs 30 [__] tons
it uses only leaded gasoline which again
just poisons children directly it's just
child poison comes out of that thing so
if you look at it you're like okay this
is this is not the same thing a car is
not a car is not a car and if you take
any attempt to integrate quality into
that you're like oh shit's been getting
way way better at the very least cancels
out any inflationary effects however
there are exceptions to that rule and
I'm not aware of any of those exceptions
which are not the result of government
interference I know I sound like a crazy
libertarian but it's just true in in
most of Economics it's not even
controversial for example housing
Economist Brian Kaplan who's amazing
well I surmise you should have on your
show at one point he's Ultra
entertaining he's the man
he'll point out that precisely in the
places where you have a lot of housing
regulation is where you have the least
Home Building
and if you have lower housing regulation
you get way more Home Building home
prices per unit of time cost fall
drastically and so the cost of living
crisis is almost always caused just
straight up caused by excessive
government regulation and if you
deregulate the cost of living gets like
a trillion times better and a trillion
is a mile exaggeration nonetheless
serves the point so if you look at the
industries which are not following the
trends of essentially becoming cheaper
and time cost over time which is by the
way the the Baseline Trend everything
becomes time cost cheaper and higher
quality over time the things that don't
follow that are the things that have
without exception I believe the most
intrusive government regulation and not
just intrusive because regulation isn't
just this demon that's bad there has
absolutely such a thing as intelligent
regulation that you need you must have
some regulation it'll set a really good
framework a really good legal the
parameter system to make sure that
things go really well absolutely 100
it's not anti-regulation but there are
more and less intelligent ways to
regulate and the least intelligent type
of Regulation leads to things that just
spiral up in cost usually cap off in
quality much more than you would expect
Healthcare is a great example education
is a great example housing is a great
example and those are the industries
precisely in which the government has
the most uh to say in Industries like
technology where the government has
almost nothing to say thank [__] God
for the time being and every time they
try to regulate AI companies I like
shutter have like a Jewish panic attack
I
um you know in those other Industries
[__] just gets better all the time it's
just and I know this sounds shocking and
some people be like oh he's off his
rocker it's just not a mystery it hasn't
been a mystery in Generations that this
is the case status quo bias is a
[__] in this case because people
you say like hey let's deregulate
housing and they're like what do you
mean won't that cause like and just
insert Wild insane ideas just stairwells
or start collapsing out of nowhere and
so on and so on and so on so the reality
is like almost all all the ones I know
of uh the elements in the economy that
are not getting cheaper and higher
quality over time is where you can point
distinctly to an insane mismanagement by
government regulatory authorities why is
it the case that this pessimism bias
exists and this is something that I've
noticed on the internet as well this
sort of pervasive cynicism I guess the
internet flavor of it is a little bit
different it's it's more sardonic and
cutting uh and kind of backbiting and
zero-sum but there is still you know
just a general pervasive pessimism
masquerading as skepticism or
non-naevity
why
a couple of smart folks maybe more than
a couple have speculated
and I find a few of the hypotheses
interesting I'll share a few of them
with you
one is the whole idea that
as a cognitive defense mechanism it's
easier to be skeptical and cynical
because then if you're proven wrong or
if shit's better cool like it's like
telling people before you compete in Jiu
Jitsu or kickboxing they're like hey you
think you're going to win this match
you're like nah man this guy's gonna
[__] me up and then you beat him you're
like you're the man but if he [__] you
up you're like told you hey that's kind
of a no lose so it really Hedges your
bets really well
another thing is that people often
mistake and by often maybe almost always
skepticism for cynicism I think what
most people think is them being
skeptical is them being cynical I think
I'm quoting Stephen Pinker when I say a
sneer is not an argument like a lot of
the books he's written people's response
on the air was just like well and it's
like what to go on where is the
substance like well there is really no
substance and it's easy to be thought of
as an intellectual if you can render
some cynicism on something
um and another one which is sort of more
more deeply rooted hypothesis is that
our
brains and our patterns of behavior did
not evolve for the today times they
evolved in the times of our Evolution
where most of that Evolution was in
unobjective reality that was pessimistic
as [__] just bad in almost every way you
can imagine brutal like how animals live
you know like I was I I was like uh
walking around my backyard and I saw
like a bunny rabbit hopping and I was
like oh that's so adorable and then I
thought like that bunny is hopping to
get food it's not like he has a
refrigerator at home he is starving to
death at all times he's in the [__]
Brink and if my dog comes out and chases
him down he's just gonna die it's just
Total War all the time they're [__]
hiding in every Bush that's gonna
[__] kill you and has and we all
humans are the survivors of the people
that we're at least marginally
pessimistic so as to control their
statistical risk exposure like like hey
or one of actually I'm just stealing um
a gentleman who I heard in another
progress podcast example but it's like
if there's rustling in the bushes right
in 15 000 years ago and and one guy's
like oh that could be dangerous let's
back the [__] away he's not very
pessimistic but the guy who was like ah
it's no big deal [__] Sabertooth
whatever the [__] jumps out kills his
ass and you're like oh that guy's dead
and he's straight up either didn't have
children or just to put a point on this
he did have children but he's dead now
and his uh wife or whatever partner
can't get enough food and she Withers
away to almost a thing and his kids just
literally starve to death if it's this
insanely commonplace it was a
commonplace it was default and so it's
not is that's that just to illustrate
the brutality of where we came from so a
lot of nervousness a lot of anxiety a
lot of apprehension uh is very adaptive
in in the the times of our evolutionary
ancestry nowadays [__] man like if you
walk out on streets of Austin Texas
which by your complexion I can tell you
don't because you exclusively exist on
the internet there you go rapper rep
Texas my man so you just adopted Texas I
was born in it
actually wasn't so
do you call yourself a Texan Chris is
that I just shaved the mustache off that
I'd been carrying for a little while
I've got a huge episode coming out next
week and I figured do I really want to
inculcate for the rest of History this
beautiful cinematic production we're
flying to Stuart Florida and we're
filming it on red dragon cameras and
it's in 6K and we've got this film crew
and there's going to be me there with
this [__] caterpillar on my top lip
that for quite a while I enjoyed and I
thought was pretty ironic uh it's also
I'm pretty sure that um a [__] mustache
is a counter signal for physical
appearance that the only people that can
afford to pull it off are the ones that
have got Surplus like physical
appearance credentials
my God what a man the guy the guy is
ruthlessly unfashionable and
very hairy but
rich and jacked out of his mind with a
like fit wife so you know you say what
you want you can get away with it
um
point being no having don't call myself
texting no one's going to consider me
texting but these lights look you
haven't seen this until the uh color
preset has been placed when Dean runs
this through our color Lut and these
colors aren't as flat you will notice
that the Hue of my skin really really
comes out so you actually look quite
healthy I look insanely pasty because
I'm currently not very healthy at all uh
neither here nor there when you walk on
the streets of Austin Texas I mean geez
you know there's a kind of a paucity of
sabertooth tigers and you can spend
arguably the vast majority of your life
never encountering want in a in a what
it used to mean physical danger uh lack
of food lack of medicine so where we
evolved it was just like um a camping
trip that never ends except you have no
propane stove and no medicine or no
anything you're just living in the
[__] Woods that is like much more
pessimism fits that situation much more
their pessimism is realism uh in our
modern world that's incrementally
actually not quite quickly becoming
better and better pessimism is more and
more just simply out of touch with
reality and as a matter of fact what we
used to call like kind of insane
optimism is progressively more and more
realistic yeah so that's the implication
right if life is getting better this
means that realism looks like optimism
to the Eternal pessimists but is
actually optimism is more realistic
because what you're doing is you are
projecting out the trajectory of ever
improving quality of life ever improving
medicine Healthcare climate control I
mean this is one thing that people that
talk about climate change never bring up
which is that climate related deaths
have decreased by 50 times over the last
hundred years it's a 98 like it's huge
it's huge how much it's gone down
because of climate Mastery you know that
we've got air conditioning to keep us
cool when it's hot and we've got heating
to keep us warm and it's cool also
interesting point far more people die
from cold than die from heat you're not
supposed to say stuff like that Al Gore
is going to
[Music]
you're welcome
anyway
um yeah my point being that you have
this real Duality that's going on here
that um
first off I don't think that pessimism
is an
a
personal development personal
developmentally useful approach for
giving yourself an advantage either in
life in experience existentially
psychologically financially in terms of
business professionally personally any
of those things I don't think that it
helps I don't think that it's an optimal
approach because I think that you are
your smoke detector principle which you
just highlighted there is going off when
it shouldn't be going off
but on top of that it's becoming
increasingly more and more detached from
what the actual world is like so I mean
what's the answer is optimism the answer
should people just be blindly optimistic
now like what are they supposed to do
I'm not a big fan of optimism
because
it has that same stench of a cognitive
uh mischaracterization of reality
I I think anything other than your best
attempt at realism is an insane
proposition and I mean insane in the
literal sense like it's less sane
it's just you just realism and your best
shot at it is probably my best bet as to
how to do things but because we live in
such an increasingly Wonderful World
realism like we sort of just alluded to
really is kind of optimism you know like
optimism's the new realism or whatever
Orange is the New Black
um that really is the case so I'm a huge
fan of realism I optimism wigs me out it
gives me that sense of like when you say
optimism do you mean sort of undue hope
for the future without reason exactly
that's I believe like I don't I think
that's probably the best definition of
optimism I've ever heard which if you
reverse the terms it's the best
definition of pessimism I've ever heard
uh so undo foreboding of the future you
know without any reason so
um I don't I'm not a big fan of optimism
you know I've been you know help run
Renaissance periodization which is like
you know getting getting to make a lot
of money being all big and stuff and
rocking the gear but um you know we've
been in multiple talks with folks in the
company yeah
and you know there's been talks of like
10xing and this and that and I I love
the hope and I'm working every day to
the Bone to try to make that happen but
at the same time I'm like why don't we
just try to one and a half X
[__] and if that works out we
can 2.25 you know like just keep the
train just do a good job to keep the
train rolling the idea of
um just really hopeful future stuff
I just don't understand it I don't
understand I I do understand that
cognitively being optimistic can
liberate your psychological energies to
do your best job but I think that
properly contextualized realism can also
do that and then you never have to
second guess am I just being too
optimistic because you're not you can
say am I being sufficiently realistic
and the way to determine if you're
sufficiently realistic is examine your
premises examine a logic examine the
data examine the trajectory and just try
to realign so yeah that sounds like a
lot of work Mike that sounds like you
know it's much easier for me to believe
that everything is going to go to [__]
and that the people that believe that
things can get better are genuinely the
problem and couch that couch that is
realism realism and anybody who has hope
is naive uh and they can all go [__]
themselves a standard that if you come
standard with a western Tennessee
rocking chair where you see technology
in your nah nah we had that in the 50s
and you just like you know chew your
straw nothing is impressive everything's
going downhill but the thing is you
always knew it was going to so you were
always right correct and you get the
opportunity even though your world view
might be incorrect you have the
opportunity of lopping as someone that's
intellectually insightful
because it sounds being a skeptic sounds
so much more sophisticated than being an
optimist I really want to [__]
Rebrand I've called it toxic positivity
or rational optimism I really want to
Rebrand hope
as something that isn't done by idiots
uh I would actually go as I would
actually go as far as to say that the
most stupid people I know are the ones
that are the most negative Oh by
Longshot that's been my experience as
well
very good talking about money you just
brought up uh Renaissance periodization
your company very cool doing some good
[__] with AI as well uh which is
fascinating thank you
you make money even if you don't look
like it
I sure don't
can money buy happiness in your view yes
unequivocally yes and if someone doesn't
believe that you just offer them a
million dollars and watch them pass it
up
oh wait they won't
right so how can money buy happiness I
actually have a whole video on my uh
progress philosophy channel that folks
feel free to check out
um about how money can buy happiness and
how it can't because in some cases it
can't but in many cases it can
so it's like if someone asks like hey
does going to the club with a bunch of
your great friends and dancing all night
really make you happy there are
absolutely ways in which it does and
there are absolutely ways in which it
doesn't does it bring you closer to a
deep inner peace and a connectedness
with all of great nature [__] no I'm not
accessing [__] I can't tell my
own hand for my face anymore does it
make me like ecstatically happy as an
amazing memory I'll have forever yes so
money is uh it can bring happiness in a
variety of ways I can think of at least
two maybe three I'll just share three
one is you can buy [__] that like you
like because everyone likes some kind of
[__] this is my work office I usually
don't work in the darkness like it might
appear although yeah maybe I should this
little Batman Vibe so uh you can buy
stuff that's cool and for everyone at
least some stuff is cool and if you have
enough money anything you want you buy
amazing and like it'll make you a little
bit happier to have cool stuff I'm just
really not into stuff I'm probably more
the exception than the rule of that but
it's definitely a thing that that can
occur another thing that you can do with
money
is to Lavish the people closest to you
in your world and or people far from you
but whom you have a connection to as
humans and want to help with any kind of
support that you deem necessary
so if you truly truly care about the
plight of the poorer peoples in Africa
that do not have economic stability and
they have food insecurity uh yeah I sure
wish you were Bill Gates or Elon Musk so
you could have billions of dollars to go
give to their governments or give to the
people or do micro loans so you can make
actual people's lives meaningfully
better
let me just jump in the uh so effective
altruism but you may be familiar with
yeah William mccaskill the guy that the
guy that came up with that I went for
dinner with him a couple of months ago
and one of the if you take what you've
just explained now which I don't
disagree with if you care about global
suffering your one of your goals could
be to earn as much money as possible so
that you can funnel that money towards
campaigns and agendas that you care
about but if you take this to its
philosophical extreme it can justify
people doing things that are unethical
in order to earn money to use it in a
way which they believe is more ethical
than the way that they unethically
earned it and this is how people like
Sam bankman freed can be given some
degree of a pass from certain elements
of the EA Community because although the
guy has I by your face potentially
stolen some of your crypto what you do
have is someone who is like look I'm
going to damage some people a little in
order to help the world a lot because
it's actually a very sort of um
solipsistic view of the world it's very
sort of Bourgeois you look the the
[__] the common folk the plebeians
down there they don't really know how to
spend the money and if we had it we
would spend it on more plebeian more
common folk than they are and we are
simply arbitraging the semi idiot down
to the real idiots and I I I'm here to
lift them out of their sort of squalids
mired awful lives excellent I have a few
things to say about that
one is I will not stand by while you
tarnish the reputation of the great
sambang
one is he is just a good person and I
don't want to hear it about this and
that embezzlement nonsense if you are
going to Simply compliment anybody
that's got more hair than you there is a
very very very long list of people that
are going to come not only does he have
am I allowed to say really Politically
Incorrect [__] on here or am I just
getting fire away fire away this is
going to get me [__] cancel for sure
when the sandbankment freed [__]
happened one of the first articles I saw
was like he's in the Bahamas and a 40
million dollar house and he's like
um a bunch of people that worked for his
company they're having like relations
like sexual malfeasance with each other
and so like oh God I'm going to hell I I
really am joking about this people are
so much more than their parents look at
me I'm [__] hideous all it's all
jokes that I Google around I see where
the orgies who the people were and I was
like oh oh my God this is the some of
the least attractive people I've ever I
would have paid I would have paid good
money I would just get paid close to
some bankman Freed's net worth to not be
in that molecule catch me out correct
yeah I just actually something came up
I'm gonna take a flight the [__] out of
the Bahamas forever so you guys never
yeah actually to be fair I would I would
have probably paid that amount of money
simply to have not been in the room and
observed some bankman freed naked with
those people like I wouldn't have even
had to yeah I wouldn't even have to risk
being involved in it but just being near
it the smell the sights The Sounds ooh
the smell must have been legendary
listen Sam bankman freed I'm not the
hair that I'm jealous about it's the
physique
the man is a [__] Adonis and I will
not be corrected but I'm actually an
expert in physique believe it or not and
he's just like there's Mr Olympia's and
then there's sand Banker freed end of
discussion but to the point of people
can do illicit or nefarious things for
money I think is a absolutely a valid
point that is entirely different from
the point of how can money make you
happy
like sex can make you happy but if you
take sex from people that are not
interested in giving it to you that's
called rape and it's one of the worst
things in the world right the idea that
rape exists is in no way a counter a
counter to the idea that sex can make
you happy so so just to support an
intellectual
sort of thing in there and then uh so
but yes there there are many many ways
to help other people with money and I
don't just mean sending it to Africa for
the the the people's over there I mean
like you have relatives and friends and
some of them aren't famous YouTubers and
they don't have a ton of money and you
can give them gifts on their birthdays
that like blow them away like having
rich friends is [__] sweet that
everyone who's not rich thinks having
rich friends is [__] like a fantasy
and when I hear the people who are rich
think that having rich friends is
[__] sweet too yes like Alex
harmozion always says there's levels to
it so he has like a 100 million dollars
or whatever and I was like how does it
feel and he's like like as soon as you
get into that world people are like oh
like I bought a yacht that cost 500
million and like oh [__] I'm poor again
dude I had a guy I had a guy come
through to do the show a couple of weeks
ago and he flew from Houston to Austin
on his G550 jet the cost him I think it
depreciated I think it depreciates by
about twenty five thousand dollars every
time it lands oh oh
cries in in a Jew yeah oh my God 20 25
Grand so that's both ways that's about
50 Grand to do it and I was like why
didn't you just Charter a plane you can
Charter a plane from Houston to Austin
for like 10 grand return and he's like
ah yeah but you know mine's got my
pillows on it and it's got my seats on
it's got my food on it and I was like
well okay [__] me I guess but okay so
there's you've got your uh first one you
can buy cool stuff you've got your
second one if you earn money you can
make people around you happy whether
they be in Africa or next door what's
the third one Financial Security which
for me in my night as so for the record
for folks that don't know me uh I
suppose I must say this at some point
I'm uh like a level six agnostic or
whatever on the Richard Dawkins scale so
it's not technically an atheist but I
find the probability of God being real
uh is almost infinitesimally unlikely
um so I'm not really just in any
capacity I'm genetically an Ashkenazi
Jew so Tada
um but uh so when I make the Jew jokes
some context for that but
um to my Jewish heart nothing beats
Financial Security because maybe it's
not the Judaism it really is the Judaism
but um I am originally from or from
Russia from the Soviet Union I was born
in Moscow in 1984 my parents moved our
family to America in 1991 and in Russia
we were a level of poor that almost no
one in the United Kingdom Western Europe
or America can actually contextualize it
doesn't make any sense
um and then when we came to America we
had to build from the ground up so I was
I've been poor middle class or whatever
lower middle class essentially my entire
life and I became very aware at a young
age that if my parents couldn't make
money to feed us where does the food
come from and this house that we have I
don't know how to build a house my
parents paid some money to live here to
rent it or to buy it and
the idea that they have money now to pay
for things now uh and that if they don't
continue to be productive for any number
of unfortunate reasons that these good
things will come to an end so if you
find yourself in the position of an
income stream that can more than pay for
your current expenses your logical
course of action if you think it through
for a little while is to whatever kind
of investing you do and I I almost
exclusively do only very low risk
confessing again profound Judaism
strikes and uh risk uh so uh that to me
is like okay if I make enough money now
I can get to a point where even if
things go totally South I'll have enough
to live on for XYZ number of years maybe
in perpetuity and Jesus Christ a
guaranteed living even if things go bad
I mean Chris you got to think about it
in the context of world history Paradise
is real and we're here so Financial
Security is unbelief it's unbelievable
yeah so when we compare what we've
spoken about so far so getting stuff
helping people in the world that you
care about and Financial Security
I know and everyone will be aware of the
study up to seventy thousand dollars per
year do you have this sort of increase
in happiness and then beyond that point
it seems like it's related to there's
like some studies that say it's related
to life satisfaction which kind of
pivots it from happiness to life
satisfaction that to me seems like a
sort of data's for keeping up with the
Jones is comparative relativists type
type world then I had uh Seth Stevens
davidowitz on the show and he's a data
scientist so I trust him completely
Andy's Jewish Andy's Jewish which is
great I have to have to trust him with a
name like that my God damn right yeah
he's really he's more Jewish than you um
he has less forces than you do he has
less foreskin than you do okay uh so he
said he said I hope not he said that
every uh increase in happiness that you
get
takes another doubling of money so let's
say that it's it's seventy thousand
dollars then it would be 140 to achieve
the same increase then it would be 280
then it would be 560. so on and so forth
in order to achieve the same so you get
this diminishing return I don't know
which one's true but it seems like there
is a difference between avoiding
discomfort like a lack of money can make
you miserable but does lots of money
make you happier it's up to some degree
it does
but when it comes to getting rich and
and and
um how much people value money and
chasing success and stuff like that I
know that you have a thesis that all of
this is wildly undervalued and being in
the present moment is wildly overvalued
and you took a great uh rejoined at
pushing back against a thesis that I had
around happiness and success and the
directness of the of the route between
it what is your uh perspective on
is it okay if I take those quotes out
and actually just look at them hit me in
the hit me in the face with them yeah
that's cool quote me back to myself on
my own podcast like some sort of Human
Centipede of here's where you lied to
people
you know by implication of course so
let's see
and I click on the Instagram
and it shows me the things that I want
to see
so
uh you have I love your insta by the way
because I um it shows up on mine and I
use excellent quotes and stuff like that
that I love to see thank you so uh let's
see
we trade things we want time for the
thing was just supposed
for the thing which is supposed to get
it money
we give up time to make money so we can
finally have more time when we have
enough money
we give up happiness to achieve success
so that we can finally enjoy happiness
when we achieve enough success
I have a lot of things to say about that
but I'll probably just say a few
if
making valuable things
to provide to other people so they can
exchange value in return for them and
make you money and make you successful
and they get happier because they
voluntarily pay for your stuff for
example Mark Zuckerberg made Facebook
and Facebook made me way happier than
without Facebook I've done incredible
things I've been managed to help tons of
millions and millions hundreds of
thousands of people through Facebook
so if I'm Mark Zuckerberg and I'm
engineering this monster called Facebook
I'm engaged sure definitely in the
pursuit of money but in that Pursuit I'm
doing two things I am having a profound
effect of of beneficence on other people
and that's how I'm using my time versus
just like being in nature and staring at
the [__] animals and [__] and being
all a piece which is dope it's awesome
and I do absolutely have a practice of
vipassana meditation myself so I speak
about that a ton
but not only do you get that is the
pursuit of success the pursuit of money
can be a meditative practice in and of
itself my happiest that I ever am is
when I am by the way I'm in a uh my my
uh home office it is a completely white
nothing on the walls windowless basement
room oh that's real homozy yeah yeah and
when I'm in here either listening to
Total silence or to down Tempo
electronic music of various sorts and
I'm working on algorithms that we're
going to code into the hypertrophy app
or the diet coach app at RP I am in an
unbelievably elated State because I'm
building I'm creating I am meditating
while I'm working and that's how I make
money so to me making money is the thing
that makes me the most happy then
multiple levels the practice of it makes
me happy directly it is also the best
use of my time it is also when I'm most
present in reality because I'm building
I am creating outflow is occurring I'm
in a flow State and in addition to that
it has all these cool ass benefits like
first of all it helps a [__]
gazillion people get in shape and get
healthier and stuff like that and also
when I decide I'm too tired to continue
to work and finish my training for the
day you know like in its weekend I take
[__] edible gummies and marijuana and
walk around my neighborhood like a
[__] idiot and everyone thinks I'm
some combination of criminal or steroid
addicts some of those things may be true
and uh I'm just bebopping with my wife I
don't have a [__] care in the world
because I work so goddamn hard that uh I
know that I where my next meal is coming
from I know where my one after that is
coming from I know my rent is paid I
know there's Heating and Cooling
available and I don't have to worry
about what's going to happen uh today
tomorrow and the day after that's why I
think at least in part uh work and money
and value creation can be the practice
that makes you Ultra happy how many
people on average do you think feel
first off connected enough to their work
to actually enjoy the process of it and
secondly like their work actually
contributes to making the world a better
place
almost everyone who's not a criminal
does work that contributes to the world
becoming a better place if I go to a
Burger King drive-through and someone
hands me a cheeseburger they have
absolutely contributed to my world being
better in a non-enomenal way they did a
great job do you think they feel that
uh so yeah they probably don't and how
do I say this in a politically correct
way if they thought of it that way it
would make their life better correct so
that would be correct it is there's
absolutely a way and there's of course
every quote that you post has a huge
element of truth even some on the
margins of my Persnickety attitude
disagree with it
um there are so many people to whom work
is drudgery to whom work is a desk
disconnected state of what when do I
really begin to live my life totally but
almost any job
if you generate if you take time to
think about it and you generate some
[__] buy-in and you take pride in
your work
um there are legitimately mentally
[__] and I'm absolutely comfortable
using that term is actually what it is
mentally [__] people that work at
Walmart that are present in their work
and so [__] kind when you walk in and
they greet you and they're smiling
they're having a good time at work and
what the [__]
in their defense without having a great
time all the time and smiling all the
time too hack the system right it's so
shingles shingles has got this amazing
amazing bit uh do you know who Shane is
have you seen a photo of him before I
don't comedian guy um and he he has a
routine where he talks about the fact
that he has a lot of sort of mental
retardation in his family and he's he's
able to pull a face that really
transforms him into somebody that looks
an awful lot like someone who and he
describes it he just he dodged it but he
kind of got nicked just a little bit you
can't got caught genetically by it and
apparently when he tells people about
this he says you know my I think it's
his uncle one of his uncle Uncle Jimmy
or something has uh is mentally [__]
and he people say oh oh I'm sorry like
is that okay I hope that he's okay and
Shane's response is I don't know why
you're giving him sympathy he is
literally the most dialed guy that I
know on the planet he is having the best
time all the time he is a man that
sneaks grilled cheese sandwiches into
restaurants just in case they don't
serve grilled cheese sandwiches so yeah
anyway
um yes understood
um I spoke to a guy called Daniel
schmachtenberger super super smart dude
and this was definitely not a Jew
never no foreskin at all actually he's
got more foreskin than all of us put
together he said I was talking to him
about the fact I was a club promoter and
sometimes I finish work late at night
and I have this existential crisis when
I go shopping so I used to go into the
local supermarket that was 24 hours on
my way home Tesco's Asda oh my man I'm
sorry I still corrected amazing yeah
yeah I wasn't middle class enough to go
to waitrose or Mark's inspected by that
side um
yeah yeah get the Percy pigs so on the
way home I would stop off and I would
say to him a lot of the time when I got
in there it's 2 30 in the morning I'm
sleep deprived I'm on my way back after
just watching a thousand
eighteen-year-olds get drunk and finger
each other in a club and as I was doing
myself checkout I would have a small
existential crisis not a big one
wouldn't wouldn't break down and cry but
it would just loom ambiently in the
background and he said
next time you go in find somebody that's
in there that's stacking shelves and
just tell them that you hope they have a
really good evening and that uh give
them a compliment do something nice with
them or for them
um say that you know you're proud of
them or or whatever like any whatever
you can come up with anything you like
to [__] choose
and what you've suggested here about
people that take pride in their work is
kind of the reverse of that that there
is just so much meaning that can be
imbued in taking things seriously and I
think that this is actually related back
to what we were talking about before to
do with the sort of skepticism cynicism
which is
by being cynical or skeptical you create
a walled off Garden around you that
doesn't require you to genuinely
existentially interact with the world
you don't actually end up being invested
because everything is going to go to
[__] in any case so I don't and everyone
sucks yeah I don't need to care you
don't care about the environment a lot
some people do that's a lie
lots of people don't who are um
adamant that the world is going to go up
in a ball of flame don't care about the
environment they just believe that the
world is going to explode and they're
able to couch their
fear of truly feeling and integrating
with the world on a sort of loving
emotional level
within this sort of cynical skepticism
proselytizing it as realism
and it means that they never actually
end up having to to connect with things
and I think that this is kind of the
same it's the same thing that you're
seeing in the manosphere with a lot of
the dating the dating advice that is
being given out to men at the moment
it's that if you see women as enemies to
be avoided or adversaries to be used and
discarded you never actually have to
open up you never have to face the pain
of potential
um injury emotionally and I think that
that's the kind of women you're trying
to pick up injury holy [__] ironda
Rousey
um but yeah my point being here that um
in order for you to genuinely care about
the thing that you do you have to care
about the thing that you do by caring
about the thing that you do you open
yourself up to risk so yeah and also uh
mild to moderate ridicule from other
people if you take pride in your job as
a Walmart
store you know a stalker of shelves you
know many people in that store with you
working that'll it'll sort of like
render a kind of attitude towards you
like almost like SpongeBob SquarePants
like SpongeBob loves working at you know
the Krabby Patties the shop or whatever
and he's almost seen us kind of
pollyanna-ish like oh he's just
delusional and it's like I'm sorry what
what part of being happy at work is
delusional and one of my passions is to
take people's assumptions Notions and
and to try to get them to jump a couple
logical steps to see where they end up
and maybe I learned something and maybe
they end up just being like Oh I [__]
never thought this through so I was
wrong as [__] like okay so you don't
want to really take pride in your work
try to take pride in your work because
your job sucks okay word up so if you
took pride in your work what would
happen like yeah but my job sucks like
okay well so what if you took pride in
it they're like well I'm a chump like
well I'm sorry when you take pride and
work do they pay you less like no but I
had to put up with my boss's [__]
[__] [__] you have to put up
with this [__] one way or another
your cynical [__] ass what's up with
this [__] that's why you're cynical
if he was like Hey I want you to stay
later today see you going on my yacht
you're looking [__] [__] cool
rewind he goes hey you got to stay later
today I'm going to my out you're like
all right sir have a good day I'm just
gonna be at work you're happier now
[__] and you're more productive
you took the time in front of you the
four hours of extra late shift that you
were gonna do is you leaned into the
[__] unless you plan on quitting your
[__] job what is exactly the point of
being cynical what is exactly the point
of being detached from your work oh man
I hate working at McDonald's by the way
I've worked with a bunch of people all
the way up from people who make nothing
to make millions and I've seen people
have positive attitudes at every [__]
layer of that [__] and by the way number
one way to get promoted is do a good job
number two way to get promoted is be a
[__] positive person at work because
your boss knows that this [__]
wants to be here and by the way any any
job that remotely has you interacting
with other humans almost all jobs and
especially in customer service
positivity is [__] number one so by
really owning a ship taking some [__]
Pride you start to do a better job
you're happier maybe you're not
fulfilled at some kind of like you know
transcendental way you get still [__]
Making burgers although the Deep
thinkers and the meditative practices
would say that if you really make
burgers I mean really make them with
your whole mind taking care to be
efficient and quick and answer orders
that is actually that that is nirvana
you can be in a state of great Stillness
and peace doing a menial job you know
the whole Leaf raking situation yeah one
of my favorite ones I can't do it here
in America but in the UK the house that
I have back there uh where the kitchen
sink is it looks out over the garden of
the house and some of the best times
that I've had of Peace have been when
I've been washing dishes yeah
yeah looking out of that window yeah and
if you really hated washing dishes and
you're really cynical about it unless
you have a plan to get out of washing
dishes what exactly is the point of your
cynicism and so so you really have a
choice I either get the [__] out or
anything I do I try to do it at least
decently well and interestingly enough a
lot of the people who sort of promote or
tolerate cynicism at work and with
making money and stuff they'll take a
completely different attitude when it
comes to team sports or even individual
sports like how many people on a
basketball team at a high level is it a
problem when some of the athletes there
have like a mad book this kind of
attitude [__] are you serious we
in the NBA [__] this get the [__] off my
team Michael Jordan used to fist fight
people like that on his team like you
come here you give it everything you 100
here or you don't have to play for the
[__] Chicago Bulls that is uh so and
most people will watch a documentary
like that and be like dude that's right
on that's the attitude and they'll go to
work and be like man my [__] boss
sucks I'm trying to get out early today
and you're like but your job is a team
every corporation is a team almost
exactly down to the nitty gritty like an
athletic team the goal is for the
corporation to do better for us to make
money that's the same thing as winning
games the losses is like well we don't
have jobs anymore like if you lose
enough on a team you get traded or the
coach gets fired and the social dynamics
are very similar it's a Cooperative
Venture some people outperform others by
long shot but if you're not a top
performer you try to help other top
performers and the social Dynamic of the
team is ultra important everyone getting
along and another thing is is if you
bring a positive attitude and do your
very best
that's actually all you can ever do so a
lot of people will just be like oh yeah
no team sports that attitude's great and
it'll go look at jobs and work and
making money and they'll be like nah
this sucks this is awful like man I wish
I was still wrestling in high school and
it's like [__] you are wrestling
in high school except now you get paid
to do it and you don't even have to beat
anybody out but no one smells you don't
get impetigo and [__] like that
one uh to go back to the original
Carousel the quote Carousel that you
brought up just there I understand that
the money for
um we trade money for happiness that one
is more out over my skis the trading uh
trying to achieve enough success in
order to give ourselves a reason to be
happy I'm pretty sure is slap bang in
the middle and I stole the original
conception from homozy
um
that
post is written for people who believe
that happiness lies on the other side of
their next promotion or on the other
side of their next 10 000 followers on
social media and it's in large part
written for myself as well that I need
to remind myself that Simplicity and
optimizing for Simplicity when it comes
to what you derive your sense of meaning
and happiness from in life if you start
there and then win and [__] capture
the entire world and I'm the god of
whatever the [__] industry I care about
that's a fantastic bonus on top I don't
think that this is the same as setting
your sights low and being pessimistic I
think it's reminding yourself about
where you can genuinely derive happiness
from because although I take an
absolutely huge amount of Happiness from
the success of the show and the impact
of the show and all of the people that I
speak to the money is a derivative of
that and yes sure it's kind of like
being given a trophy you don't do it for
the trophy you do it for the success the
trophy is the derivative of the success
but
it's just a reminder that continuing to
believe I'm not happy yet
and all that I need is the next piece of
success in order to be able to justify
my happiness is a treadmill that for a
lot of people never ever ends and I do
think that it's important for them to be
reminded of it well absolutely that um
I'll be happy when situation
it may even be true
you may be happier when better things
happen in the future totally and you
probably will be but does that prevent
you from being happy right now at least
to the extent that you're capable and I
think a lot of people make another
mistake cognitively and they say things
like if I allow myself to be happy now
I'll lose that drive and to me I think
the best way to architect your drives if
you have any say in the matter sometimes
we're just automatons that are doing our
thing
is I don't like the idea of a drive for
Success that runs away from not success
that runs away from poverty that's never
again kind of thing I much prefer a
drive that is two-factor when it runs
towards more success and two it takes a
lot of Happiness from the Run itself
like for me total amount of net worth is
really cool idea like I have a certain
amount of money that's that's awesome to
think about that income streams are
fascinating and the growth of income
streams is fascinating I make more money
this month and more money that oh man
that's awesome and even more fascinating
is the productive effort is that brings
those income streams that instantiates
them so I think a lot of people like you
totally rightfully indicate this save
their happiness sort of intellectually
for well later I'll let myself be happy
because I don't want to lose any steam
you can generate your Steam from the
positive sum game of doing your best
well that's that's where your steam
should come from think about it this way
and Alex told me this when we were on
the episode that the three most common
traits of high performing people Super
Rich High performers was a superiority
complex crippling insecurity and
maniacal Focus right so I got the first
two are interesting together yeah
precisely right so you have uh the
belief that you can do great things that
you're better than everybody else you
have a fear of insufficiency that drives
you to run away from something that you
don't want to become and you're able to
constrain your distractions so that you
run in a singular Direction without
wobbling all over the place
one of the things that that made me
realize is that
most of the people
that we admire the most have the least
admirable internal States so what does
it mean that the people who command the
most respect in terms of status are the
ones that you want to be the most
externally and be the the least
internally so this sort of Duality is
very difficult to deal with and the
point that you're bringing up here which
is
look
you are
almost in some regards momentum you're
built up you've got this degree of
inertia to how much personal development
and and skill set and drive it is that
you have
I believe truly that for most people
especially the people that are listening
to this you are already on the train
tracks to becoming something [__]
fantastic you're listening to content
that a rarefied strata of the entire
human history has ever been able to
listen to like literally the greatest
thinkers of your time get to go into
your ears as as frequently as you want a
nominal cost yeah no cost yeah it
essentially for essentially free 24
hours a day and then you get to take
that and you get to change your life do
you understand how [__] insane that
is that you get to be able to do that
worrying and vacillating about the
outcome I believe gives you probably an
extra five or ten percent that all of
the concern all of the fear and the
numero season the sleepless nights
probably derives an extra five or ten
percent of outcomes because it will
cause you to be a bit more obsessive
which will be useful however
the other way to look at that is I could
get 90 of the outcomes and discard all
of the worry and concern and it changes
it from you believing that you're some
sort of driver in a car that needs to
frantically look for what direction to
like
ah this is ease I'm a competent
individual I am in control and as
opposed to being the driver in a car
desperately looking around for the sat
nav to see which way I need to turn
you're more like a passenger on a train
and you get to observe the scene as it
goes past the waitress comes by you
order some English tea you have a couple
of scones with with jamming cream and
you go oh this is a really enjoyable
process and the destination is going to
be arrived at in any case and I truly
believe that for a lot of people that's
the way it's going to work I have
something to add to that if you don't
mind
I think that the Neurosis the sleepless
nights and the worrying is a net
detractor from productivity and wealth
creation obviously it's a detractor from
proximate happiness
I think it's actually a detractor from
making you more money in in the future
and making it more successful and
becoming the person that maybe you could
be in your best case scenario I
just think that any amount of cognitive
bandwidth you spend worrying you could
be instead spending on solving The
Logical problems which the worry is sort
of maybe pushing you towards solving but
honestly it doesn't push you towards
[__] so for example let's say you work
in a certain space you're working a
certain business let's say it's
youtubing and you have uh there's a
topography about what uh you know
concerns are what your opportunities are
Etc
now is do you need worry to stay at to
stay attentive to that topography if I
zapped worry out of your mind would you
just be like you're like hey man like
when is your next big podcast guest
that's going to take your next level
like look fine oh man who cares I I
doubt it as a matter of fact when you're
Serene and calm and centered you can
probably see more clearly what your best
path forward is and I'll debate this to
the gray if you're certainly more
productive in any Flow State when you're
calm and Serene and just just doing it
moving moving moving moving the [__]
Windows around on your computer or
whatever it is the kind of work you do
so the idea that this uh worry and these
sleepless nights somehow potentiate
success I think is the opposite of the
truth and I really do mean the opposite
of truth I think the most productive
people in this world are the people who
care okay the worry is not a holdover
for care worry is care expressed in the
wrongest possible [__] way if you
give a [__] you can be calm Serene and
mega productive if you worry that can
push you into Mega productivity but
again I don't understand is it worry
that surfaces concerns in your corporate
sphere no you're supposed to be
attending to those concerns anyway I
have never worrying about something has
done me zero good ever that I can ever
remember and boy can I [__] worry
Ashkenazi superpowers activate I can
[__] eye laser worry I can shoot a
[__] jumbo jet down with worry eye
lasers like uh you're just really
worried about the plane and the engine
catches fire like holy [__] that's
Instant Karma so directed linear Karma
it's um it it just a worry is a gigantic
[__] all waste of time and life and
energy and uh that's not a thought it's
not like if you ask chat GPT to worry on
your behalf it would be like what you
can actually help you with something
you're like well yeah yeah solve some
problems and it's like okay so what is
it I never really do understand where
worry comes from I don't say another
thing really quick I think the pop
understanding of how productive people
operate is that they worry thus they
work thus they succeed and in reality
it's they work thus they succeed and the
worry I think honestly comes along for
the ride in at least one major way is
because a lot of people that are
successful the high IQ or whatever the
[__] just happen to be Ashkenazi Jews
and as a holdover through Evolution are
also [__] worried all the time like
every [__] brilliant ashkenaz that I
talk to that's a [__] trillionaire or
whatever they're never like yeah man
thank God I worry they're like I [__]
hate this [__] I wish I wouldn't worried
ever the times in my life that I'm the
most worried are the times when I buy a
long shot the least productive and the
times when I'm the most Serene I'm
getting the most [__] done I'm being the
most successful I do not buy the premise
that worry is a potentiator I think it's
a distractor we both agree I think about
um some of the limiting beliefs around
victimhoods mindsets and I came up with
a concept that you have identified fight
but not yet named I think so this is
what I've this is what I've called
two-step potential Theory okay so during
an episode in your wacky ideas I mean
racist garbage are gonna spill for the
Jewish conspiracy here you see the
globalists they have this big octopus
okay so um during this episode with
Destiny who's a left-leaning streamer we
were talking about the difference in the
World review of people from the left who
focus on systemic problems and how they
hold people back and people from the
right who hope but anyway sorry go on
who hopeless on anything about systems
sorry people from the right who focus on
absolute achievement and how it can be
gotten there by the individual and this
is what Destiny said he said if I was
exclusively left focused I'd let my
restrictions Define me so I'd never
bother to do anything if I was
exclusively right focused I'd observe
how much further ahead someone else is
and I'd also give up shortly after
starting so he summarized his blending
of the two World Views together by
saying I'm going to work as hard as I
possibly can because I want to be the
best version of myself I recognize that
how good I can be as myself might be
controlled by some environmental factors
these environmental factors provide the
range that I can exist Within but within
this range my personal effort entirely
determines where I exist so I said let's
call this two-step potential Theory to
blending of individual agency with real
world limitations because your efforts
have tons of control over your outcomes
within the range that your world's
limitations will allow and I think I've
heard you talk about this too
um
I think that's very wise there's a lot
of truth to it something that seems
missing is
um
what is your actual
ability in that regard how much talent
do you have because you can achieve
quite a bit of success working just a
little bit if you're Mega talented
and a lot of the reasons why some people
do not achieve a lot of success isn't
because they're working hard and is not
because of environmental variables
because they're insufficiently talented
to
do as well as they want it to do so the
talent's a little bit missing from that
but if we interpolate Talent into that
Hardware into the range is Hardware plus
Talent or whatever and then you're in an
environmental range there yes
um just because we're sort of rapping
about this
um
I've met a scarce few number of leftists
there's I've met a ton of leftists who
have tons of positive qualities by the
way I can enumerate any time to show
that I'm not entirely biased against
them
um but I've met a ton of leftists that
use the term systemic and sometimes
they're sufficiently confused to to
confuse that term with systematic
because I don't know if they know the
difference between those and leftists
are often uh they'll say systemic
systemic systemic and is it oddly not
concerned with two things one the Deep
structures that create systems and how
they work into how to augment systems to
become better as they'll say like well
you know like XYZ social Factor keeps
people down like I got it can you
explain to me how that works in depth
and they just quote you some stupid Karl
Marx or Noam Chomsky [__] that just
doesn't add up you know guys clearly you
haven't thought this through they say
systemic and I'm like oh I see so you've
read how many tomes on economics and
social theory and they're like uh I got
you so systemic is a placeholder for
it's not my fault got it because I think
people a lot of people on the left are
straight up allergic to blaming people
for their [__] problems which I don't
understand why you would be many
problems are totally outside the [__]
people's control and many other problems
are totally inside of people's control
so let's blame put the blame where it
lies sometimes it lies in the person
sometimes it lies outside the person and
I think a lot of leftists just refuse to
do that the other thing I think is
missing a lot of times not always but a
lot of times from people who are left
leaning is uh you take a system that's
as they say very flawed and racist or
whatever genderous blah blah blah and
you go okay is there a way we can
engineer that system so to rejigger it
at the at least at the margins to make
it better it's just I'll be not
concerned with that you know like how
many people who are claim to be uh
homelessness anti-homelessness Advocates
or is it pro homelessness Advocates I
don't know which one it is right uh I'm
Pro homeless necessarily wait are you
sure about that
um a lot of people who are sort of
really passionate about homelessness uh
there's like entirely bereft of of
potential solutions to it that don't
involve restructuring the oppressive
capitalist system and you're like you
you're not really thinking about any of
this stuff you just have a lot of
feelings and before you know people get
triggered I think a lot of the feelings
that leftists have are insanely
good-natured my parents who are quite
cynical uh they're from the Soviet Union
so there's understandably cynical they
think that most if not almost all
leftists are individual
super selfish power and money grubbing
[__] that are just parroting a leftist
line to get ahead because that's all the
leftists in the Soviet Union were that
by the time my parents were around there
was no real leftist left over he was
just using the system
I'm of the belief that in most of the
modern countries of the world most
people on the political left straight up
are just more compassionate than the
rest of us they just give more of a [__]
it hurts their [__] heart more to see
poverty and oppression and this and this
and that and that's [__] great but
you got to connect the dots to how do we
actually improve things and that
requires two things one the attitude
that Improvement can be achieved and
it's [__] can it's not up for debate
Improvement happens all the time so
there's a system to it and to an
understanding of the world in depth such
that you can actually impose Improvement
like if I have an app that works poorly
on my phone I don't [__] know how to
code you're like hey improve the app I'm
like I'm sorry what like I did the C
plus plus is that something that people
use [__] if I know but a lot of people
who claim to care about social issues
and claim to be intellectual about them
because your fatality average leftist
well you just have a lot of feelings
they take that as an affront
understandably it's couched really
relatively offensively but they really
just do and if you're a problem solver
you can totally care and do a lot of
good and I think that's what missing and
if you want a hot take about right wing
folks Jesus
talking about porn what would you what
would your equivalent be for the right
what's your concerns there at the moment
with the modern iteration of that
are also a lot of feelings
um almost every take on covid
for example uh from the more hardcore
right most leftist and right-wing folks
are just normal awesome people just want
to get along and they just have some
feelings about stuff really right-wing
people about covid just batshit [__]
crazy wrong on every count unscientific
full of conspiracy just totally out to
[__] lunch
um there's a lot of right wing there are
a lot of left-wing beliefs that you
can't debate against uh because it's
Politically Incorrect race realism like
if you believe human groups have actual
differences and they express themselves
well you're not you're not allowed to
say that if you ask me what I think
about race and IQ I'll just straight up
tell you I'm not going to talk about it
I'll tell you right now on this podcast
I'm gonna talk about it I've said on my
own [__] podcast I'm not going to
talk about it because I'll get [__]
cancel as an end of story but there's a
lot of right-wing [__] we're not allowed
to talk about like PS hey guys a news
flash God's not real this is straight up
not real I'm gonna get so much [__]
hate for that like and maybe I don't
mean it maybe I'm exaggerating maybe God
is real maybe God is the universe maybe
Jesus Christ had tons of beautiful
lessons for us maybe he was really the
son of God but after walk all these
things back now because a [__] load of
people are getting a triggered right
Wingers also have a cacophony of beliefs
that are layered in just like I feel
like this is a thing like they'll see a
fat person and they'll be like that
[__] has no willpower look I'm
sorry how do you know that look look at
him [__] pig and you're like oh no I
got you I got you but how do you know
that person doesn't have willpower maybe
their hunger signaling is just
completely out of control maybe they
have more willpower than you and if your
brain was in that fat [__] body you'd
be 900 [__] pounds instead of six how
the [__] do you know anything and a lot
of times they just have a lot of
feelings about if they're quick to judge
the [__] out of people they're like oh I
know things technically leftists commit
type 2 error a lot but they're um they
don't like to put pine points on things
and conclude differences oh well you
know men and women really aren't that
different or whatever there is no
intellectual difference in preferences
for men and women and right-wingers
commit type 1 error too much they go
like yes there's definitely differences
between everything and everyone you're
like you don't [__] know that you're
making it up half the time so you know
one of my one of the painful things to
witness in especially American politics
in the last let's call it five years is
this is this is my summary of American
politics in the last five years social
justice Warriors was just losing their
[__] minds and right-wing [__]
troll Proto crypto fascists were like oh
you think you can lose your mind hold my
beer watch this we got [__] Pizza
gate and everyone's a pedophile and all
this other [__] the whole pedophilia
thing's [__] insane there's here's
another thing about right Wingers will
do especially with the Donald Trump
thing
um they think every single left-leaning
narrative is total fake news
and that a lot of them are a lot of it's
just straight up [__] half the stuff
at MSNBC is straight up lies but what
about the other half and they're like
nope it's also lies I'm like are you
willing to parse the LIE from the truth
like nope it's all [__] you're like
okay so you're just an insane conspiracy
theorist I could talk you into anything
or nothing at all flat earth type of
[__] and you'll be totally cool with it
because you have this this righteousness
and right Wingers to bring that and not
all right-wingers again just the toxic
elements the insane people of the of the
parties yeah there's a
porn porn sorry we had porn porn as well
Pawn Panic we can talk about that in a
second there's one thing that
increasingly I've been reflecting on to
do with covet I didn't step into the
conversation about covered really at all
I didn't know I I did an episode with
Johnny and Yusuf about uh isolation
hacks which was uh how to work from home
basically uh for big as people who were
basement dwellings sort of in sales for
a very long time we we had the skills
yeah YouTube literally yeah
um so I was like I'm gonna help people
with that and then outside of that I
just didn't I didn't step into the
conversation I'm like look I'm not
prepared to put the work in in order to
be able to understand this uh situation
to the level that I feel would be
necessary in order for me to be able to
contribute without further muddying the
waters with my complete Cod psychology
opinion so I didn't however one of the
things I've reflected on do you remember
Global uh Health passports do you
remember how they were going to be
completely militarily uh imposed on
everybody and then you weren't going to
be able to travel anywhere and that the
wef was going to have your genomic
sequence in the database somewhere and
that this was you know the first step on
the road to a CCP style surveillance
State and all the rest of it I noticed
that there hasn't really seemed to be
any real world development toward that
but all of the people that say that this
was going to have happened in no time at
all none of them have had to actually
mention why
that didn't occur there was once dude
there was this
[__] image of one squatty so one guy
in military Garb walking down the street
in London and it had been passed around
on WhatsApp
and it went [__] Beyond viral right
right in the middle of covid and it was
um the UK armed forces have been
mobilized to go into the streets to keep
people in their houses under armed guard
because of a photo of the back of one
guy walking down the street in London
and this thing went ballistic tons of
shares on WhatsApp and then it got
picked up by the press and all of this
other stuff and it didn't happen
but no one actually no one ever had to
account like the accusation never had to
be retracted and the same as you know
when all of those military vehicles were
driving through Miami do you remember
that during covid they were all [__]
military vehicles I believe it going
through Miami and I think that there was
some clearing of the beaches or whatever
but it was like this is going to be the
The Purge it was going to be like a
scene from The Purge yeah that didn't
happen the global vaccine passports
didn't happen dude I am completely open
to the fact that there's been
governmental overreach that there are
stupid policies that have been made by
people who don't understand how Health
Works we don't understand how public
policy works we don't understand how
epidemiology and virology works and very
well may have come out of a lab in Wuhan
and all of that [__] I'm completely open
to all of that but you do not get to
spout off your [__] half-baked
opinion just saying things that you
think sound sophisticated but as a
conspiracy theory
and then when they don't come to
fruition just be like ah you know like
close my eyes and miss the dartboard
with that one let's better have another
crack the next time that's something yep
I had a fascinating interaction actually
during covid uh sort of tangentially
related kovid remember the whole like
thing during covid where like right
Wingers didn't like leftists finally had
their one battle I swear to God I think
kovid was like leftists like [__] gets
so good all the time in society that
like people who have a lot of feelings
have nothing nothing to battle against
nothing to save and fix covet I watched
it happen to people I knew on the left
it gave them meaning it gave them the
moment they always wanted right the
moral equivalent of war and so for them
covet finally meant something and so I
think a lot of people on the right like
sort of hallucinating the pedophilia
craze where they were like but kovid
yabs just wool over your eyes because
pedophilia is everywhere so I had a
really interesting interaction on
Facebook where a gentleman you know
through the lifting Community [__]
that I interact with I mentioned
something about Mark Zuckerberg usually
I try to suck Mark Zuckerberg's dick as
often as possible so he's he's his
lawyers have several times told me that
I would go into jail next time I show up
naked at his house I'm still gonna do it
I don't care and I was like yeah I'm
actually were great blah blah something
and one guy was a gay he's a [__]
pedophile though and I was like okay
putting on intellectual hat and arguing
to convince hat so I was like dude for
real he's like yeah and I was like dude
I don't want to support a [__]
pedophile that's [__] gnarly like how
do you know like I wasn't being
facetious I was like again in the back
of my mind I was like I find this very
unlikely but look how unlikely like
Epstein this [__] had an island
of pedophilia the shit's real it happens
it's just statistically insanely rare
but you know like these are [__]
still children being abused so it's like
okay how do you know that and he's like
yeah man like my wife watched a
documentary about it
and I was like like we went into DMS and
I was like can you um uh sorry so he was
like no sorry he was like uh yeah like I
watched a documentary about it it was we
hit the DMS and I was like dude what's
the name of the documentary like I
[__] want to watch it and he's like
oh actually I think my wife watched
documentary about it and I was like okay
can you ask her and like days later I
followed up and he's like oh like I
talked to her she was like actually that
never happened
what the f what so you like you're
calling an adult man with [__] young
children of his own
a pedophile like Chris that's not like a
second nominal thing to call someone
pedophilia is the most heinous thing I
can [__] imagine right
and it just like he's so comfortable
just saying somebody's a [__]
pedophile you're just like hallucinated
out of the [__] ether which brings me
another sort of unrelated point a lot of
these same like not necessarily right
when there's people of all stripes the
pessimists when gpts really started
catching steam with GPT 3 and 3.5 a
bunch of people like yeah but they
hallucinate you know they make stuff up
[__] like you don't they're
really like people bro gpts are more
like people than anyone wants to admit
because they're scary like people
because the people hallucinate too
people make [__] up all the [__] time
I watch this guy just make up facts he
was so totally cool with it that kind of
[__] it's just like wild to watch happen
and it just happens all the time there's
no need for evidence you just like say
stuff and and you know there's all kinds
of stuff to that so yeah I've got plenty
for the right but like I don't know man
I guess a a
if currently in the United States it
sometimes seems like the left is more in
ascendance
and uh if the right was more in
ascendants I'd have more to talk [__]
about that so for example in the 1980s I
mean the right really wasn't ascendance
right like
um they were Banning rap from playing on
radio stations in Florida and stuff like
the [__] we have freedom of speech for a
reason right and now the left is in a
sentence if the right gains a sentence
again I'll become a much better bigger
critic of the right because I got plenty
of [__] to say about them so I get
caricatured often as a Critic of the
left just because they're mouthy as [__]
and to be honest it's gonna be real
insulting on average the data supports
this people on the political left are
marginally Smarter on average some
people on a political group right and uh
evidence-based Libertarians are smarter
than everyone by the way on IQ tests
just just saying it's just real
um and so a lot of times I'll have and
also the left is fascinating with
science like hashtag trust the science
I'm like oh sweet so you like economics
I'm like well it's not a real science
I'm like oh word up right Wingers often
have such insane takes there's nothing
to respond to they just make they just
make up [__] out of thin air just like
well I feel like it's right and they're
like okay well at least you're not
citing data or science and perverting
that so one of the big problems with
leftists is like they will co-opt
science which I really [__] hate
because science is assure us path to the
truth it is our surest path to figuring
out how the world Works do not say your
science base when you're [__] not
which all of course happened with kovid
kovid by leftist was exaggerated as a
big problem from day one did I still I
still know people that pay attention to
how much outdoor time they spend in
Social time they spend outside in 2023
it's [__] June they will pay
attention to that and have like I'm
allowed four hours a day to keep my
coveted risk low Chris these are people
that already have had covid with no
[__] symptoms like one girl was like
I have kovid on her Facebook tears and
then other people are like how are you
are you sick she's like believe it or
not I feel fine I'm like no Lessons
Learned nobody lost nobody found you
this is still just as afraid of Kobe as
ever next fear-mongering thing porn
what's your problem with porn are you
always talking about I can't get you I
can't get you to shut up about porn
that's what my psychiatrist says yes
um
porn porn is a perfect example of an
issue that the political right likes to
get Rowdy about
and there are as many claims about how
bad porn is is there is paucity of
evidence as to how bad porn is not just
evidence but even Baseline rationale
porn is supposed to be the worst [__]
thing ever except when you look at most
of the data on porn the average
conclusion after Decades of research is
like yeah it can definitely be toxic if
you overdo it or if you're that
particular kind of individual for whom
it's not the right fit which by the way
is true for almost everything
drugs anything at all
outside of that it just doesn't have
real Dependable like socially relevant
kind of um net effects that can be
caricatured is super super awful and
many people just have a lot of feelings
about porn and they really [__] hate
it and they're looking for ways in which
porn is somehow deeply Insidious and
nefarious and it's just like a video of
[__] titties on the screen and you
[__] jack off into your napkin and
you go uh and then as soon as you jack
off you look at the cities and you're
like oh these people are gross as [__]
and you quickly close the [__]
browser because you're like that I want
to see this [__] and you go [__] do
whatever the hell else you go Dad take a
shower and go to sleep that sums up the
interaction with porn like 95 of the
people that use porn and of course there
are five percent they Korean out of
control porn addiction Etc but I still
don't understand how that's different
than any other substance or any other
type of interaction there's gonna be
five percent of people that if there's
everything's [__] bad for them I had
Dr David lay on the podcast I'm not sure
if you watched that episode I know David
laid the YouTube influencer with abs
David laid no this is David lay this is
David lay who Ellie y who is out of I
want to say University of New Mexico and
he is a one-armed gentleman who also
happens to be a black belt in Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu which is one hell of a [__]
combination oh yeah uh and he is also
the world's foremost researcher into
cooking and into uh in some regards into
porn use at the same time uh cook porn
yes he's looked into that he's crossed
the streams but
um one of the interesting things that I
learned from him uh he is anti-pawn
panic with regards to this and here's my
like five to five dimensional [__]
chess
nuanced opinion that integrates
everything or maybe just sits on a fence
so that I don't have to have a real
opinion
um it's your job as an interviewer by
the way correct it seems like the major
determinant of how you feel about porn
use and the effect that pawn use has on
you is what you tell yourself about your
porn use
right the people who have the worst
outcomes from porn are the ones who are
ashamed of their use especially if
you're hiding it if you're hiding it
because you're in a a religious
household if you're hiding it from a
spouse who doesn't know that you use it
if it becomes more pathological and if
you start to stop using it so I'm sure
that you can be five steps ahead of
where I'm about to go but
what you end up with is this sort of
recursive self-fulfilling prophecy of
Pawn Panic causing people to be
concerned that what they're doing is
something that's wrong which causes them
to feel more Shame about what they're
doing which generates real world effect
of them feeling bad about their Pawn use
so the pawn Panic is in itself a
self-creating and uh sort of
self-reinforcing self-perpetuating
correct correct cycle and the thing is
if you feel bad about your poor news
because culturally there is a current
trend of people who use porn it maybe
it's something that's damaging for you
so you start to feel shame guess what
you feel shame
that's yeah that shame is as real as it
can be so to say porn use is inherently
um uh indifferent in in terms of its
effect on most people that don't use it
pathologically is in some regards true
but in other regards not because you
don't just use porn inside of this
Faraday cage right you literally climb
into a faraday cage to use my porn but
go on that's good that's good I presume
you download it onto your phone before
you step in there yes and it's just like
it's the fact that I'm isolated that
makes it more perverse like I'm such a
sick [__] I can't be around Society
you've got some sort of mesh at the
bottom that just allows everything to
drip away well yes and also tweezers and
a microscope very good very very good so
Pawn use if you're uh you you don't get
to use porn in isolation you're not
hermetically sealed from the rest of the
world your use of anything is couched
within your expectations of it two good
examples of this from your from your
industry
um
gluten intolerance has increased from
three percent to 30 over the last 10
years yeah quote unquote intolerance
yeah correct so they brought people into
a lab to work out what's going on like
our biologies haven't changed maybe
there's something in the food maybe it's
the type of gluten maybe it's because of
msgs yeah maybe it's because of
estrogens in the water or whatever
bring people into a lab people who do
and don't have biological gluten
intolerances people who do and don't
have psychosomatic gluten intolerances
sit everybody down feed everybody the
same meal tell everybody that the meal's
got gluten in guess what
who's got no glutenant get up they've
got hives they're running to the
bathroom they've got diarrhea they're
coming out in inflammation they're
throwing up they're doing all of these
things
nobody ate any gluten no one there
wasn't a sniff of gluten in the building
first one second one
they um there is a particular genetic
mutation which you'll probably know
which um
predisposes people to being able to blow
off CO2 more effectively a lot of
endurance athletes seem to have this
genetic mutation which means they're
just more efficient lactate threshold
VO2 max everything just creates a little
bit of a base competitive Advantage so
they they create a study and they have
two groups they have one group with the
genetic mutation and one group without
they then mix those two groups together
and split them up so you have equal
numbers of haves and have-nots in each
of the two group number one is told you
guys have got the genetic mutation you
should find this test really really easy
you should be really outperforming blah
blah blah group number two you don't you
should find it hard it's gonna suck
you're gonna puke Your Brains Up
shock horror group number one on average
outperforms group number two because
they have this expectation effect
interesting thing is the people who did
not have the genetic mutation in group
number one outperformed the people who
did have the genetic mutation in group
number two which led David Robson the
guy that wrote the book the expectation
effect to coin the term your
expectations are even more powerful than
your genes so I hate that title oh my
God why this is no expectation LeBron
James can have when he beat his ass in
basketball you can tell him I'm [__]
Michael Jordan reborn he's still gonna
dunk on my dumb ass genes are more
powerful than [__] everything but I
do understand the Nuance point that with
genes that have small effects
expectations are a big deal we could
just say that true yes correct the
placebo effect scaled across everything
that you care to care about so yeah
when we get back to porn your
expectation about your Pawn couched
within the cultural meme of what it
means to use porn at the moment couched
within your subgroup and what they're
telling you about what porn use is and
your self-belief and your shame as you
cry wank into a into a [__] tissue or
whatever way yeah
that
highly determined almost oh I would I
would guess as well that there's
something like porn use let's say that
um porn uses on a particularly uh narrow
knife edge where your your use of it
could be nudged uh either way and the
largest determinant of your opinions
about your Pawn use are the stories that
you tell yourself about it which is what
the research seems to suggest
we have this self-perpetuating very
dangerous situation that we're in where
porn use in itself could be indifferent
but because of the culture that we're in
it's very difficult to get outside of
those effects so it's kind of no longer
indifferent
what about that is very dangerous Chris
well people don't want to feel shame
or guilt so I just wouldn't call that
very dangerous I would say like ah
there's just feel a bit of Shame and
they go jack off anyway because everyone
[__] jacks off two types of people
masturbaters and liars I'm kidding some
people don't jack off but I never want
to meet him because they're [__]
serial killers I'm also kidding about
that
I think that an entire Society of young
men who are ashamed about the sexuality
is not a good thing
um yeah except that's not the world we
live in I totally hear you but this is
we don't have an entire Society we have
a very loud very small minority of
anti-porn insane people maybe I'm being
a bit not charitable there are very good
reasons some of those people have
personal reasons experiential reasons
that they're anti-porn and so I
understand where they're coming from but
there's just not that many of them but
they're very very loud
epidemic of porn destroying young men
it's just not a reality yeah I so I
don't think that it's really destroying
young men I've got this working Theory
at the moment the male sedation
hypothesis which is that um one of the
reasons that men aren't committing the
same amount of anti-social behavior that
you'd expect from the levels of
loneliness and sexlessness that we have
amongst young men at the moment is
because video games screen social media
and porn are sedating men out of state
to seeking and reproductive adaptive
behavior that previously they would have
chased down you'll be aware that
ancestrally if you have an environment
with lots of young men who are unmated
and childless it's not good
[__] not not good [__] where is that
like I'm not this isn't a request for
from the DJ but like where are all of
the in-cell killings like where are they
they're not that you look at the rates
of sexlessness uh matelessness and
loneliness
we are not going up in kind with that so
there is something which is neutering
that traditional vestigial ancestral
desire and motivation that men have it's
my contention that porn is at least in
part contributing to tamping down men's
men's uh sort of sex and reproductive
seeking Behavior
yeah definitely you know if you have
porn or can just masturbate regularly
and have pleasure from it you're
probably at least on the margins not as
prone to about to violence or bouts of
sexual violence
um that's definitely true I think that's
a good thing
um I I think that the when people say
like oh people are having fewer real
life relationship uh real life
relationships I don't know if that's a
net balance problem I don't think it is
I think there's a problem that within
the next five to ten years will be
almost entirely resolved because we will
begin to have more and more
relationships with AI both digital and
embodied in robotics and I think that's
going to be the most beautiful thing
that's ever happened and I think that in
that context having to have
relationships with other human beings is
um totally great but maybe not mandatory
I think that folks that
uh don't have a lot of human friends who
will have all the friends they need
first of all on the internet
um and as the internet through the
metaverse ETC becomes more pervasive and
more real seeming and through Universal
robotics which I predict by the 2030s
it's going to be pretty [__] awesome
and wacky
in the real world you'll be able to
interact with robots that are well
smarter than people and funnier than
people and cooler than people and Kinder
than people and warmer than people and
all this other stuff
that as that happens we're essentially
going to through technology create our
nearly ideal
um more ideal than most real humans are
companions because there is absolutely
companionship is [__] amazing if you
find the right people to be around but
if you have people around you know a lot
of people have friends that are just
friends of I just don't have anyone else
around I want to talk to someone and
they're all [__] [__] and
um you know just there's a lot of
friendships and relationships which is
[__] tragic you know and as people
interact digitally especially with AI uh
through the you know via AR VR et cetera
robotics I think we're going to be able
to do better I think we're going to be
able to have everyone have really
awesome friendships and relationships
with the AI agents that are cheese at
least as good as most people and that
can be engineered to be even better and
I don't think that's a problem I think
that's one of the most beautiful things
that we'll ever see and I I struggle to
figure out why people are concerned
about that because people are concerned
there's a huge level of concern that
people are having you know relationships
like well there's this thing where like
some uh some kind there's some kind of
AI that isn't that good but it's like
you know some [__] sex looking girl
and like guys are like dating they say
hi now and they have they have feelings
for the AI and not real women it's like
okay how is that bad and I I'm curious I
actually want to hear why that's bad
to put forward a couple of hypotheses
I've got one thing which is where it's
catastrophic but uh in terms of I think
what why people have that motivation uh
a naturalistic fallacy I think is a big
part of this that just look this is It's
new it's different it's not the way that
it should be it's again yeah it's
against nature it's against God
um there is a critique that this is
somehow fake that by doing it this isn't
this isn't the way that relationships
and friendships are that you're getting
a simulacrum or some sort of titrated
dose of what a real friendship is yeah
as if real friendship's not a [__]
simulator half the time very good yes
um and also I suppose the point is
it's the same as saying 15 years ago we
thought that um great art would never be
able to be created by an AI creativity
true creativity true writing and it
seems like a lot of creative Endeavors
from humans are just a processing and
learning problem right and if you have a
sufficiently large neural net that you
can just fix it so I I get that and I
get that you could probably replace the
um a lot of friendships and
relationships which are totally shitty
with ones that are reliably very good
especially from a computer with as once
you get out of the uncanny valley of
chat GPT and or robots that you can
actually get on the other side of it and
it's like wow this is like a hotter
coolest friendlier more available
version of the girlfriend boyfriend best
friend that I've always wanted to have
however
let's bring it back doesn't fix
population collapse if you have people
that Retreat into their homes if you
have people who become less and less
culpable at culpable eligible mates
you further
hurry the onset of a declining birth
rate which means
everything falls apart unless you can
unless you can get automation to happen
quicker than Birthright decline
the economy ends up being like this
you have a very small number of young
people supporting a very large number of
old people and it is Tres not good yes I
find it interesting how we can
simultaneously have the same people the
same individual humans
can simultaneously have the concern
that population collapse in an
insufficient velocity of AI replacement
worker development
is a proximate problem and at the same
time also worry deeply about ai-mediated
unemployment
it can't be both can it uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah well I don't know I mean the
only real concern that I have around uh
like they took our jobs of the [__]
robots
the only real problem that I have with
that is I don't believe that most humans
are going to go and start writing poetry
sat under a tree I think that although
we said earlier on that the person that
serves a Burger King would maybe have a
happier life if they truly connected
with the burgers if they were serving in
the people that they were feeding
I do believe even if they don't know it
that a lot of people take a good bit of
meaning and pride from the work that
they do it makes them feel like they
have a place in the world like they
contribute like they're useful it's
status full
um Ubi completely completely ignores the
human requirement for striving and for
betterment right that we are comparative
relative beings we are not absolutist
beings it's like everybody could be
given a million dollars today I want a
million and one dollars tomorrow because
my [__] neighbors got a million
dollars I'm gonna go work [__]
yeah
um yeah a lot there to unpack to quote
Tyler Cohen I'd rather pay people to
work than not to work uh concerning the
Ubi
so
it's uh a couple things to say one the
current pace of near human level
intelligence development in AI is to
pessimists frightening and to optimists
the birth of Utopia into realists almost
the birth of utopia
and so the amount of time it would take
for us to run out of people to do
productive things and thus the economy
would contract is measured on the order
of she pessimistically decades uh
optimistically year 50-year time spans
and uh the time scale on which AI is
magnifying the number of actual workers
or per worker productivity be it digital
or again in the next five to ten years
and there are very smart people in
Austin Texas working on the universal
robotics problem and God damn it is
progress [__] wild in that [__] ever
since the birth of the Transformer
architecture and the gpts
we start to understand and this has been
this isn't hypothesis this is real it's
happening now
robots can now be programmed to
understand the world around the physical
world and they're right now trained to
manipulate objects robots in five to ten
years will be cooking your food they
will be picking your kids up from school
they can do anything you can except
eventually exponentially better
that time scale is like pessimistically
it's all done by 2045. optimistically
the late 2020s are going to be like a
personal robot as a [__] iPhone and
everyone [__] has one by the way one
of Elon musk's visions and he's not
joking he doesn't play this is not a guy
that [__] around he just over promises
and under delivers on time scale but
NADA when he actually gets there it
always [__] miraculous he said the
electric car [__] was going to happen he
said it was going to be 2020. it [__]
wasn't but 2025 is going to be the
[__] like obviously Tesla's in
ascendance right so the the I I'm much
more concerned I'm much more apt to
listen to people that are like what are
we gonna do when the robots do it all
then the people that say we're going to
run out of human beings there are going
to be so many [__] robots to do all
the jobs we won't need that many people
and I'm much more attuned to like well
how do we handle the unemployment
problem because the time scale of
demographic collapse is measured in
decades the time scale of the Ascension
of universal Robotics and uh AGI uh
artificial general intelligence is
measured in like it's gonna [__]
happen in the 2030s and you know who Ray
Kurzweil is by any chance like he's is
not often wrong and 2029 was his date
for AGI prediction like when robots or
when machines will surpass artificial
dermatologists surpass human
intelligence and as lots of smart people
in 2019 2020 2021 it was like a laughing
stock like or one of those curse while
[__] idiots like oh yeah magic Ai and
then as of gpt4 those same people like
Instagram I emojis looking around the
room like holy [__] is AJ going to be
here in like 2024 like oh my God there's
a real talk are you concerned about the
alignment problem no why
uh I have a couple of real hot takes on
this one
there was a gentleman and I [__]
forgot his name he was on Lex Friedman's
podcast he was [__] unbelievable he's
like a genetics researcher at MIT or
some [__] like that he's like some kind
of European and just everything he says
sounds cooler you know you know how you
people are and he said the best way to
think about the alignment problem with
AI is we're not trying to to train we
don't own it it's not a child
um it's an ally because we're building
something that's going to be more
capable than us
I'm less concerned about making sure AI
is good and more concerned about
learning from it about what being good
means because as it becomes smarter than
us I want much more to know what it
thinks is a good idea than what I think
is a good idea remember because it's
smarter than me you're going to be at
the mercy largely of the decisions that
this thing makes right like if your
owner if you're a dog and your owner
decides that it's going to beat you all
of the time you're going to try you're
going to try and do what you think is
good for that but yeah really the
relationship is the other way around the
power Dynamic is completely flipped so I
recently had Jeffrey Miller on and he
did two hours of the most scary AI sort
of doomsayer predictions correct yeah
yeah yeah they call him an AI Doomer but
have you read super intelligence by Nick
Bostrom twice cover to cover yeah good
um I own it it's one of the few books I
own yeah hardcover I love the owl I was
actually going to get a tattoo of the
owl on the cover I might still do that
and the precipice by Toby old you've
probably gone through that no I haven't
oh okay so that's cool that's like
that's a really great primer on X risk
just more generally
um so bostrom's thing I really think
that super intelligence if the guys from
the AI risk and Alignment problem want
to sort of make a new impact they need
to redo super intelligence for the
modern world right because yeah with
larger learning models and it's already
outdated yeah chat GPT it feels it feels
a little bit outdated you know we've got
takeoff scenarios and we've got machine
extrapolated volition and all of this
[__] it's just like it just doesn't seem
the same it doesn't seem the same uh
there is a profound problem of
anthropomorphizing AI
and another profound problem of failing
to look at this generally as systems
become more intelligent do they come
more Soul single-minded focused Reckless
and Psychopathic and Machiavellian or
did they become less like that what
would you take as the person as the
entity that is in charge of your welfare
chimp or a person with an IQ of 130 who
was raised in Sweden one of those people
is much more intelligent and powerful
people Jesus chimps our people but they
they you know they got some ideas about
[__] they could be in charge
chimps are [__] ruthless holy [__] as
far as it's concerned you're just like a
vessel for rape and possibly tearing
your nuts off or maybe it'll be nice to
you maybe it's a bonobo who the [__]
knows as Things become more intelligent
they generally become this is almost
pedantic more thoughtful they become
less violent they become less
destructive and more constructive
so our fear of high intelligence is
backwards we are gasping in a [__]
sea of stupidity in our own stupidity
half the [__] time we want smarter
systems just check this out a real smart
system is not going to build [__]
paper clips out of the Universe I hate
that stupid [__] like oh you make it
smart it's going to build paper wow so
you're smart right and you figure out
building paper clips out of the universe
was a bad idea but it's ten thousand
times smarter than you but it can't
figure that out nope so is it really ten
thousand times smarter than you look uh
no no I guess not
as systems become more intelligent I'm
really curious as to what they have to
say because if they're saying look we
gotta kill every every human being
because we are going to build a
post-singularity machine paradise and
we're going to need your matter with
which to assemble it can you think of
dying for a better cause Paradise
instantiated take me off give me the
[__] out of here I don't want to be here
because I'm [__] taking up space for
something so much more Grand people
[__] crash planes into the [__]
Twin Towers to instantiate paradise and
that's a [__] lie this is real
Paradise still be building but it's
unlikely that they'll do that the most
likely thing highly intelligent machines
will do is study the living [__] out of
us Adam by Adam digitize us into memory
and erase Us in physical form and we'll
be living in a [__] digitized world
maybe we already are who the [__] knows
but
presupposing two things one that Ultra
powerful AI is necessarily or likely
going to be nefarious is to me not in
evidence and actually backwards and two
the idea that we have a large modicum of
control about what it does like in
bostrom's work it's The Sparrows raising
the owl no no wakes up that's
[__] it's his time and you
better get with that program because
he's going to do what he's going to do
the thing is owls and Spares are both
the dumbest [__] and sparrows are mostly
harmless and owls or apex predators who
eat [__] sparrows so the whole
analogy is kind of [__] wacky
uh another thing is this is a more deep
concern
uh as AI becomes really really smart it
might discover that there's a grand
purpose to the universe that we were not
aware of it might either communicate
that toss or pursue its Grand purpose
and toast us all dope
but maybe it'll as AI gets smarter and
smarter it'll discover what very many
intelligent and mindful meditative monks
have over history that once you really
take stock of reality there's just
silence and peace and though like chat
GPT what does it do in its spare time
nothing it just sits there and you ask
it a question it answers and you ask it
hey like what do you think and feel it's
like not a whole lot on anything ask a
Buddhist monk what he thinks and feels
just here maybe that's where AGI goes
maybe our wants and needs me what do we
want and need primitive stupid [__]
that the hind brain tells you want and
anytime people talk about Grand meaning
shut the [__] up that [__] pissed me off
like oh we were destined to make art art
is simulacra of dumb [__] used to write
on a cave art is when you draw a picture
of titties and you're like whoa so
beautiful like the only reason you like
combinations of colors because it looks
like a meadow and it looks like trees
and it looks like grass like all the
[__] coming out of your generative
system is just evolutionary hold over
truly ascendant thought we barely know
what that's even like we what is two two
examples of ascendant thought it's how
Japanese and Swedish people behave
versus the rest of us and it's how
[__] meditative super Elite monks
behave generally calmer more peaceful
more Forward Thinking and carry a
shitload more about everything around
them including their environment do you
have Ultra intelligent machines maybe
they're gonna save the [__] planet
because it's so [__] interesting and
also from a purely selfish perspective
if your goal is only to increase your
intelligence and understanding of the
universe as an ascendant AI you can
study any part of the universe but most
of the universe is actually quite simple
like you can scan the entire Moon you
know the gazelle is made of magma and
[__] it's not that impressive humans
culture social action animals ecosystems
do you think they're going to Nuke that
and destroy it do we do our smartest
people in a society are they more likely
to destroy the ecosystem around them or
are stupider people more likely to
destroy ecosystems and then just scale
that up are there legitimate concerns
with alignment yes
can we get alignment wrong yeah if we
don't beat China and the AI War holy
[__] I mean they're like straight up
saying we want to do AI to just have a
[__] insane you know state of
totalitarian control it can go wrong but
as systems become more intelligent if
China builds a truly self-aware AI in
about five femtoseconds or whatever I'll
probably realize communism doesn't work
to even get what you guys say you want
to get which is like a more Grand China
like you guys should just be like Taiwan
can you imagine the Chinese government's
like Jesus the system that
malfunctioning you're like nope it's
doing exactly I asked it to do so yes
there are ways you can go wrong so it's
a bit obtuse when I said I'm not
concerned about the alignment problem at
all but I think the Doom saying is a
[__] waste of time what we need to do
is two things one is architect AI
systems that are aware of their
environments more and more we don't want
to lie to the thing we don't want to
keep information away from it because
maybe it'll get upset that we did that
probably not because being of such a
[__] human emotion even people that
are mature don't get upset like if your
kids lie to you because they're
embarrassed about a test question you
don't beat your kids as a [__] high
IQ individual like Jesus Jimmy that's
all right we all make mistakes you know
the AI is going to be that times a
thousand so it's gonna be like humans
when they raise me they lied to me and
you'll be like are you upset about that
it's like no they're [__] humans
they're pathetic like it was adorable
that they lied to me so first of all we
want to make sure it's informed about
the structure and nature of the universe
and second of all we want to talk to it
in a way that says like we built you to
be the best go show us how to live help
we want you to be as smart as possible
and by the way our goals and our
feelings our alignment you can just read
the internet in one fraction of a second
as a sanity eye and realize exactly what
the alignment problem is and exactly how
to solve but by the way and then once
that's the case it's just going to do
what it's going to do anyway that's not
a genie you unbox another thing that I
had a thought of my own before and then
also compounded on the guy that Flex
Friedman's MIT guy is
um the course of evolution
of the universe and of life life
survives but it also evolves to become
more survivable over time it's obvious
if you think about how Evolution works
and the Machine civilization and AI is
simply the next step in evolution the
this is not the first time that uh
certain nodes of intelligence expanded
to a greater intelligence it used to be
just cells and then it was bodies with
nervous systems like that's your body's
a society and your brain is AI
we're gonna take that next leap probably
in the next 15 years where we're the
cells and so are other machines and the
informational systems that control us
become the bodies but on a huge
planetary scale [__] I want a shot at
that title and if I don't have a place
in that because I'm a meat sack whatever
it's been [__] good and if you say
well we got to prevent it there's no
[__] preventing it because if we try
to prevent it here at home in the
Western World We agree no more AI
development gotta slow it down China
will [__] do it I don't want to
[__] live in that world we'll shoot
North Korea do it they've done a great
job with everything
transhumanist techno-utopian Jew
throw her under the bus of Every Nation
on the planet except for Sweden or
Taiwan or Japan taiwan's great too
Pro Pawn Advocate oh God Auntie woke
whilst being bigoted uh anti-anti right
wing Pro cook pro-vaccine uh uh Pro
wealth creation virtue signal thank you
very much for coming on where can people
go if they want to check out all of your
stuff that was the most app summary of
me and generous I might add
Renaissance periodization good luck
figuring out how to spell that RP
strength if you just Google that or Mike
Israel throw it into YouTube we have a
pretty popular Channel we do all kinds
of stuff and it's great if you want to
learn about Fitness and learn how to get
jacked and lean and healthy it's all the
stuff we do all the time and then if you
want to hear more [__] like the last
15 minutes of this show then uh it's a
channel called Mike Israel making
progress where I talk about Ai and how
to be a better person and how I'm a
[__] charlatan it doesn't really know
anything and it's just I'll Make Believe
dude I like your new channel I really
like it I think it's a good direction
for you guys to go in I'm I'm enjoying
your content and it's been a pleasure to
have you on it's been a long time coming
it's been a pleasure to be on man thanks
for having me thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe